you're in the film with natalie portman
yeah you are 6'3 she is 5'3 and i'm
curious because you can't tell when
you're watching the movie so are there
elaborate special effects to even you
two out a little bit what are you doing
uh
you know there was one time when we
kissed and we had to have a she had to
stand on the box basically to you know
yes
but this time we had to basically walk
into the scene toward each other and and
embrace and kiss
and it looked silly her going you know
like this
she gets in the same frame with you and
then suddenly oh sometimes
and uh she has a little wheel
so so what they did and is they built a
ramp they built a ramp yeah so it was a
nice gradual uh you know
uh lift to the kiss so she would walk up
a ramp as we kissed
that's really so uh everyone should get
one if you're shorter and you're yeah
there's a lot of probably smaller guys
out there that really want to like bush
bars had a ramp somewhere
no it is there's famous stories about
you know i think uh movie stars from the
30s i think alan ladd it was a big star
was very and and so they would put if he
had a kissing scene the actress would be
standing in a trench yeah like dig a
trench so that i've stood in a few
trenches you stood oh they make you
stand in transit yeah or just you know
really wide sort of stance
i swear to god i swear to god it was uh
real you're in a romantic scene and
you're just here
if it shot from here upwards you know
yeah like this yeah
you just look really cocky when you're
doing that
hey baby
[Applause]
come here baby
we have a clip here um from thor the
dark world and uh i believe this is a
pretty intense action scene if i'm not
it was this is um an escape scene uh not
to give too much away between myself and
uh loki tom hiddleston and natalie
portman's in the scene too and we're
bickering as brothers do about
you know how to you guys have a great
chemistry too
yeah it's great tom's fantastic i mean
we started this journey three years ago
together and at the same time in our
career and had no idea if it was going
to work and so to be here now with the
third one and it'd have this affection
and you know is uh is amazing so let's
take a look at this clip from thor the
dark world
not a word
now they're following us
now they're firing at us yeah thank you
for the commentary loki it's not at all
distracting
well done you just decapitated your
grandfather
imagine
we're in the actual they built a
physical sort of set with the spaceship
and then yeah it's surrounded by green
screen and having to kind of pretend
you're going this way and you know
there's no hydraulics in the thing and
right so it's kind of ridiculous
uh it's working so don't change your
thing